The celebrations of Kwanzaa are relatively recent.
The holiday was founded in 1966 as an African equivalent to Christmas and Hanukkah.
There are many different reasons for celebration incorporated into this holiday.
Reconnecting the life, community, and culture are a large part of what this holiday embodies.
Freedom, justice, and equality also play an enormous role in the meaning behind the festivities.
The holiday lasts one week and is celebrated between December 26th and January 1st.
The actual celebrations include lighting candles on the kinara,...
...feasts, gift giving, and traditional African dress.
The central meaning behind Kwanzaa is to reconnect to one's African roots...
...and meditate on the world and the joys of life.
Appropriately, the official greeting of this festive holiday is "Joyous Kwanzaa!".